[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
government borrowing surges as inflation
pushes up interest payments on the
national debt
grocery inflation eases for a second
month as the cost of milk Falls
French billionaire Patrick draw he
raises his stake in BT
plus a rebound in the Food Services
sector I'll be speaking with the chief
executive of SSP group a bad return to
profit and a new partnership with
brewdog
[Music]
foreign
business and economic news from the
heart of the city interest payments on
the national debt swelled by The Soaring
rate of inflation meant that UK
government borrowing came in higher than
expected last month the government
borrowed 25.6 billion pounds in April
the first month of the new Financial
year which was ahead of the 22.4 billion
pounds that had been forecast by the
office for Budget responsibility and it
compared with 13.7 billion pounds during
April last year it was the second
highest April borrowing since monthly
records began in 1993. the office for
National statistics said the increase
was driven partly by the government
schemes to support households with the
high energy bills and increases in
benefit payments but the ons also
flagged higher interest payments on the
national debt a portion of which is
linked to inflation interest payments on
the national debt hit 9.8 billion pounds
in the month that was up 3.1 billion
pounds on April last year and it was the
highest a figure on record
our falling milk prices have helped
bring grocery inflation slightly lower
for a second consecutive month
come to our world panel which tracks
Supermarket sales and prices measured
the annual rate of grocery inflation at
17.2 percent for the four weeks to the
14th of May that was down from 17.3
percent during the previous four week
period but it was still the third
highest level since the 2008 financial
crisis we'll joining me now it's Fraser
mckevitt he's head of retail and
consumer Insight at Cantor Fraser
welcome to you are you surprised grocery
inflation isn't coming down more rapidly
yeah it's a little bit disappointing
isn't it and we Rosary inflation lags
the more General rate of inflation
because it takes a while for things to
get from the field uh through the supply
chain and onto the um onto the shelves
and through the tills so we are seeing
some movement in the right direction and
there is a good news so the headline
around milk so it has come down to about
one pound sixty to four pints which is
down about five percent from where it
was just a month ago that's great news
but it's worth bearing in mind might be
down versus last month but it's still
considerably up on where it was last
year and inflation is typically a
year-on-year measure
have you noticed any of the operators in
particular cutting milk prices I mean
traditionally it's been a bit of a lost
leader for the likes of Aldi and little
and I mean I've seen other Supermarket
CEOs refer to it it's it's a category in
which profits no longer are made
well I think it's one of the few items
and one of the few categories that
people actually might be able to say
what the price is and it's so
competitive the market that when one
retailer moves it down others will tend
to match them on this particular product
and we know that in the last month quite
a lot of noise has been made from some
of the biggest retailers in the land the
likes of Tesco the likes of Sainsbury's
on this product so it is fairly
widespread across the market
obviously we heard last week from the
competition of markets Authority they're
not going ahead with a full-blown
investigation into the grocery sector
right now I mean as someone who watches
this sector very very closely I mean
it's your job basically I mean is that
the right decision I mean competition is
pretty intense isn't it
yeah whether you love supermarkets or
you hate them and we all have an opinion
on them you have to admit this is a very
competitive sector margins are pretty
slim here so in the region of two to
four percent and we're also for the
latest uh set of results relatively few
public limited companies in this space
now as private Equity has moved in but
both Sainsbury's and Tesco's reported
that profit was down so it doesn't on
the face of it see that a market that is
particularly profiteering at a difficult
time for all their customers
now we've talked a lot in the recent
past about uh own Grands uh taking off
in the cost of living crisis versus
branded products you you note today that
the Gap is narrowing yeah the Gap is
narrowing but still quite wide so um own
label products are growing about twice
the rate of branded products but that is
coming down we've seen Brands get a
little bit of a boost this month because
Sainsbury's have launched their neck to
prices initiative which is very much
focused on branded products if you use
their loyalty card and that has done has
added quite a bit of the sales or to the
brands this month
now obviously this month was the
coronation uh period what uh special
features did you see
well it was quite there was a little bit
of skepticism wasn't there wasn't the
nation going to get behind the
coronation and in the the week of that
we actually saw sales go up by 16 so
whether people were celebrating uh the
monarchy or just having an extra bank
holiday weekend we don't quite know but
during that time it looks like more than
200 million pounds extra was spent
during that week and no surprises the
big sellers the things that really went
up sales of fizzy wine more than doubled
and still wine was still up by Third in
that week as well and you noticed that
waitrose got a boost during the
coronation week I mean that feels like
people trading up
well it does feel like that and you know
we know that the waitrose Shopper
typically tends to be a little bit older
um which might well correlate with um
people who were enjoying and celebrating
the coronation but they were the
retailer with the biggest uplift uplift
in that coronation week
also uh I mean looking at the market
shares more broadly I mean the other but
one of the key points that you bring out
is that Morrison's enjoyed his third
consecutive period of say sales growth
it can one definitively say now that
it's turned a corner
well it's it's really hard to say in
this market because it is so competitive
but it's got to be good news now they do
still lag their Rivals by quite a way
but they've been making a lot of noise
in recent days they're bringing back
their more card a physical card moving
away from an app so I think might might
find their consumers might find it
easier to use and there's a lot of
marketing going on talking about the
prices that they're going to offer so
they certainly are making a really good
effort to get the retailer back up to
speed and back in the pack with their
Rivals and notice also Morrisons are uh
offering some quite attractive
promotions on petrol right now I mean
obviously that was one area that the CMA
lighted on last week I mean Morrison's
fighting quite hard in that particular
corner of the market right now
yeah and it is very competitive in in
Petron and again one of those few things
that people might actually know the
price of and of course there's apps that
out there will tell you which retailer
be it petrol retailer or a grocery
retailer is offering the best prices and
we know that petrol does drive footfalls
to stores I'm going there for my petrol
it's a big purchase I may be spending 50
pounds and then I'll pop in for a few
items either it's a convenience store
that's just in that petrol station or
pop into the main store as well wow all
right Fraser good to see us ever thanks
for joining me today
some other business news stories for you
now and the French billionaire Patrick
draw he announced this morning that he
has raised his stake in BT from 18 to 24
and a half percent shares of BT though
have hardly moved on the announcement
and that is because Altis UK the vehicle
through which Mr draw he has bought his
stake stressed he has no plans to launch
a takeover bid well Altis which controls
France's second biggest telecoms group
sfr first bought a 12 stake in BT in
June 2021 and it raised it to 18 later
that year the UK government subsequently
investigated the investment under
National Security laws but said last
August it would be taking no further
action
John Allen the former president of the
CBI is stepping down as chairman of
Barrett developments at the request of
the house builders board the news comes
four days after Mr Allen stepped down as
chairman of Tesco and follows four
allegations in the Guardian newspaper
about his personal conduct well three of
those have been vehemently denied by Mr
Allen while he's unreservedly apologized
for the fourth which concerned
inappropriate comments made to a female
member of staff at the CBI well
Barrett's board said today it was in the
best interest of the company to
accelerate a plant transition to a new
chair to prevent the ongoing impact of
the allegations against Mr Allen from
becoming disruptive the investment
banker Caroline silver will replace John
Allen us Barrett's chairman
RS groups the electrical components
distributor warned this morning that
trading during the last seven weeks had
pointed to a slowing in industrial
growth the 4100 company also said it was
seeing continued weakness and aggressive
competition in electronics well the
update came as RS previously known as
Electro components reported a pre-tax
profit of 371.5 million pounds for the
year to the end of March that was up 23
on the same period a year earlier RS
said that sales growth was strongest in
the Americas where it benefited not only
from an acquisition but also price
increases
the Norwegian chemicals company Yara
International said this morning it's to
build a new fertilizer plant in
Yorkshire the company said the plant
would produce specialty crop nutrition
products and biostimulants designed to
increase Farm yields and improve quality
it said the site would be located at
Howden near its existing site in
immingham and is aimed at doubling its
UK production capacity the aim is for
the facility to become operational by
the end of 2025.
thank you
well Equity markets in the Asia Pacific
region traded largely to the downside
overnight amid unease over the U.S debt
ceiling the Nikkei in Tokyo which
recently hit a 33-year high fell along
with Hong Kong Shanghai and Sydney
although there were gains in Singapore
and in Mumbai well in Europe stocks are
also trading to the downside this
morning you can see they're all the main
Continental European indices in negative
territory right now talking points today
include the Danish drugs giant Novo
Nordisk Denmark's biggest company by
some distance the shares are off two
percent in Copenhagen amid concerns of
growing competition to its weight loss
drug wegavi well here in London the ftse
100 is just about in positive territory
it's more or less unchanged they're
looking at that losses for Industrials
are balancing out gains for some of the
property heavyweights this morning the
leading blue chips are indeed land
Securities and British land both of
which updated the market last week and
both two percent of the good there as
you can see on the screen to the
downside while the leading Faller
mentioned them a moment ago is RS group
that's on its results outside the ftse
100 panel group is off by one and three
quarter percent and that is after off
what launched an investigation into
leakages at its Southwest Water Division
among the gainers in the mid caps today
will the meat producer kranswick it
shares a nearly four and three quarter
percent higher as its results have been
well received today meanwhile watches of
Switzerland company that we've featured
quite often in the recent past on this
program it shares ahead by some three
and a half percent on mounting
speculation that the government is to
reintroduce fat-free shopping for
tourists that would be a huge boost for
that particular company on the foreign
exchange markets well a bit of breaking
news in the last hour we've had the
latest flash purchasing managers index
survey data for may obviously anything
over 50 represents growth there anything
below that represents a contraction of
reading for April for May came in at
53.9 that was down from 54.9 in April as
you can see the pound has sold off on
that new it's off nearly a third of one
percent right now against the US dollar
it's off a seventh of one percent or so
against the US dollar uh The single
currency meanwhile off an eighth of one
percent or so against the Greenback as
for the oil price it's been very little
change this morning not much uh going on
there to uh talk about uh Battle of
Brent crude currently off a third of one
percent right now that takes a barrel of
Brent crew to
75.73 a barrel or joining me this
morning is in Quigley he's head of
financial planning and Investments for
Ireland at Brewing dolphin Ian good to
see you again this morning
um we're reaching the end of the latest
quarterly earnings uh season what have
been your takeaways
um biggest takeaway is probably the
resilience and the recovery for some of
the big U.S tech companies
um which reported better numbers and
they're obviously a big part of the
global market big part of the US market
outside of those companies you've seen a
decline in year over year earnings
um
but you know better than what was
expected earnings estimates were revised
down beforehand so nothing two
kilometers and interesting when you look
at Market history when companies are
reported modest declines or very modest
gains or modest declines it's been fine
for the equity Market because often the
market anticipates a decline in advance
like it did last year so from here it'll
be more about how earnings will get
revised as the year progresses and how
the economy performs but the earnings
season was fine and probably better than
most expected it absolutely is I mean no
sooner is the market uh got over
worrying about that though then we've
got this U.S debt ceiling situation I
mean tell me the US isn't going to
default on its debts please no well yeah
I think it's this classic kind of
prisoners dilemma slash game of chicken
that we're seeing at the moment and
um I think logic it's logical Prevail
markets assume that logic will prevail
and and and they'll increase the debt
ceiling it is obviously the case in U.S
politics that has become more polarized
over the past decade so you can
understand why in all likelihood it's
going to go down to the last minute
um so both sides can sell out
particularly the Republicans to the more
extreme part of their of their party
um and again it's it's we kind of all
anticipate that that's what's going to
happen but you're kind of going through
this going through this dance
um but yeah with the extreme shift and
part of the Republican party that
probably makes it a little trickier than
previously but you know you would assume
logical will will prevail there yeah we
all have to be experts on the the
Republican parties in ins and outs at uh
these sort of occasions but I mean it
strikes me in this this is being used as
a bit of a sort of catch-all when when
the market feels like going down people
will just sort of attach themselves to
that particular story
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that's often
the case isn't it What markets were both
Market scope you find the narrative to
explain why it went up and vice versa
um I think what you know reflecting on
on on the last year and this year if you
remember recall as I'm sure you do at
the end of last year started this year
the overwhelming consensus was that the
start of this year was going to be very
difficult we might get a rally in for
the second half you know lo and behold
most European markets are up double
digits nasdaq's up I have 20 out percent
and S P's perform very strongly as well
so it's it's moved counter to what the
consensus expected and and gets often
off off in the way with markets
um and you're from from here included
the debate as it was through the second
half of last year when will the economy
go into recession or if it goes into
recession what type of recession that
would be and it'll be you know those
those discussions around the economic
cycle will be you know Forever at the
Forefront of people's minds
um I know for us you know we've got to
place the emphasis on investing for the
long term because again if anything you
know the last six months a year just
shows you how difficult it is to predict
the economy absolutely and obviously uh
that feeds into interest rate
expectations as well I mean we haven't
talked much about uh the Eurozone this
morning what are your thoughts on the
where DCB goes from here
well they're saying they're going to do
more uh sorry I should have looked at
the Futures before coming on but they
say they're going to do more And the
guard's still talking pretty tough
um
you know it is quite remarkable to think
in March last year German Bonds were
negative yielding and now one year
German bond is three percent so it's
been a hell of a move
um and perhaps you know we see it here
in in Ireland as well and then across
the Eurozone that's not really flowing
through the banking sector because Banks
aren't paying particularly High interest
rates or it's not necessarily flowing
through on lending rates either so there
might be a bit of delayed effect of that
you can see the NASA prices you can see
the the sectors that you expect to be
most vulnerable like property last year
but perhaps it's going to take a little
bit of time for the moves that have
already been taken to flow through to
the economy you would expect it to slow
the economy and and you would expect
interest rates perhaps
um to ultimately
come back to a lower level but it's just
how far central banks want to go how
worried they are about inflation and how
patient they may or may not be a better
coming down absolutely Ian always good
to see you thanks for joining me today
thank you
looking up across to uh Westminster now
MPS on the treasury select committee are
questioning senior figures from the bank
of England including the governor Andrew
Bailey and the chief Economist Hugh pill
Mr Bailey's just been asked why
inflation is higher than when he last
appeared before the committee we're just
going to listen in signs of that because
obviously the peak was 11
and we have seen the benefits already of
some some of the benefits of energy
prices but it is it is higher than we
expected to be and there are two
underlying reasons for that that we see
in in the data one is food
uh and the second one is
some Goods particularly clothing and
Footwear now what should I should just
make the points that it's it's
interesting to note that those are not
the elements of inflation that we regard
as the more persistent elements that's
more in the services sector whereas so
far it's tracking more or less as we
thought it would in February but we have
seen your right your rights say we have
seen these upsides on these particular
two areas what's gone wrong then either
with your models or with your network of
Agents uh you know it's not something
that many of us would have found
surprising at food prices for example
were persistently strong that our
farmers were telling us about how much
inputs were costing them and things like
that something has gone really wrong
modeling and with your network of Agents
Edge in terms of information on food let
me let me say it's obviously a question
that we've spent a lot of time on as
well as you can imagine
what I would say is that back in
February
um t23 yes this year so yes
um
the contacts that our agents were
talking to this is a point where food
price inflation I think it was around 15
if I remember right that's the food
element
and the contacts were telling our agents
that they thought that was the peak
and that it would come down from there
onwards over the rest of this year
now you're right that has turned out not
to be the peak we've invested a lot of
time and efforts
including me going around the country
talking to the contacts again to say
what what has caused this to happen
I should say that they are they remain
of the view that it is going to come
down
um but it's obviously it's gone up in
the meantime now there's two reasons
that
um I would say or two groups of reasons
they give and they say look they were
wrong in this view
um
the first group is things that I think
it's reasonable to say couldn't have
been expected in other words events that
have happened in the meantime they in
certain elements of food and they're
mainly weather events around the world
frankly so there was a well-known thing
with vegetables
um in I think it's Morocco particularly
sugar is a is the one commodity that is
still when it costs the board his price
is still Rising the there are a series
of weather events in other parts of the
world given for that so there's some
things like that there's also a story
about avian flu
those things are things that I think
genuinely you know you can't predict
from sort of you know from period to
period
I think the second thing it is however
the question and it goes to what you
were saying a few moments ago
um and I think two things I get told and
I was on a farm last week actually
um uh talking to a producer uh who's
also a producer of final output as well
and they said two things one is
energy the impact of energy prices on
businesses is quite
it's quite unevenly distributed it's not
like domestic energy household Energy
prices which have been in a sense set by
government policy it really depends on
when you renew your energy contract I
mean you may pick this up in your
constituencies some businesses you know
have done done much better because the
timing of the reset of their energy
contract worked in their favor
um some have had the absolutely opposite
effect and so it's very uneven
I think the second thing is and this is
perhaps where the prediction issue comes
in I think
what was possibly underestimated is the
degree to which food producers have
purchased
more forward in terms of raw material
suppliers than they would normally do in
other words they've locked in higher
prices for somewhat longer and the
reason they did that is related to
Russia Ukraine actually which is they
were worried about the absolutely
actually getting older so so the farm I
was on last week said they bought
fertilizer further forward than they
would normally do locked in a higher
price than that now I think that should
I mean I think you're right we you know
question you know it should have been
possible to identify that I think I mean
it's hard it's a bit harder to quantify
but it was in there somewhere in the mix
whereas the weather events weren't and
we'll be coming back to food later on in
the session but if I can turn to Hugh
and ask the same question do the
responsibilities for the forecasting
models fall within your area Hugh most
of them do yes so what's gone wrong with
them
well I think I mean I would Echo a lot
of the things that have already been
said
um I mean it is very difficult to
forecast
uh at very high frequencies some of the
developments that we've seen given the
magnitude of the shot to take an example
in in the governor's letter to us well
if you want to continue watching those
questions to the bank of England uh
Executives you can click on the QR code
on the screen which will take you now to
our live feed from the treasury
Committee in the meantime we've got a
bit of breaking news for you uh the
pandemic the warn Ukraine and climate
change uh no we're not coming to that
first we're going to we're going to talk
about the shell AGM which is taking
place right now uh there has been some
disruption at uh the show AGM uh some
climate change activists have got into
the meeting I think we can show you a
quick clip of uh sir Andrew McKenzie the
shell chairman uh dealing with some of
these people let's uh just see if we can
get that to you
come back no more
[Music]
not function
s
that's uh sir Andrew McKenzie there the
uh shell chairman there uh disruption
was protesters worth actually pointing
out most uh shareholders in Shell are a
bit peeved at just how much the company
is spending on the uh transition
compared with some of its uh American
Rivals such as Exxon and Chevron but we
will have more on that throughout the
morning no doubt here on Sky News
now the pandemic the war in Ukraine and
climate change have all highlighted
vulnerabilities in the food supply chain
around the world creating shortages and
pushing up prices but the global food
system is also going to be subject to
other enormous changes in coming years
including changing preferences chiefly
for a more Western diet as well as
technological innovations such as crop
science and lab-grown meat so how should
investors navigate these changes well
joining me is someone who's just written
a paper on it tomahertz he's Chief
Operating Officer at PGM the 1.2
trillion dollar Global asset management
company timer good to see you this
morning I couldn't work out from reading
your paper whether you're actually
optimistic or pessimistic about the
outlook for Global Food
I am uh convinced that it's at a cusp
at a point of transformation where carry
the food system as we have it now in is
not fit for purpose the system's broken
you've got 25 percent of people in the
G8 obese and overweight and you've got
800 million malnourished people at the
same time the Ukraine war has just shown
what geopolitical tensions and energy
price increases can do to food inflation
and food prices and you've got this
three-tier technology in food where
you've got like Precision agriculture in
the US and Europe you've got large-scale
mechanized farms in Argentina and Brazil
and then you've got Bullocks and Farms
that's in 10 acres in India so it's ripe
for Change and there's lots of
opportunities for investors behind that
change
but we feel that change is desperately
needed because climate change is really
exacerbating all these tensions that
I've just described in the food system
which would an agrarian revolution in
China and India along the lines of what
we had in this country a couple of
centuries ago helped the efficiency of
food production in those countries
absolutely a lot of the technology the
sensors the way to measure water all
these places where there's opportunities
in Venture Capital to invest have sort
of got limited to the US to the Europe
and to Latin America and you have small
scale farming and this technology hasn't
adapted to the needs of those countries
they're new companies for example
there's gramophone in India small
company that's on mobile devices
providing Indian Farmers information on
seed technology when to plant what are
satellite weather patterns looking like
that is all needed because Indian
Southeast Asian African technology
really hasn't Advanced since the 1960s
Green Revolution and a lot of advances
have come elsewhere that we need to sort
of adapt to those worlds and that will
cause a big increase in food production
which is again going to be down 12 just
because of climate change which is
really alarming I mean you make the
point that uh western style diets are
going to be the growing preference I
mean that is more resources intensive
can production keep up with those
changes
production can keep up with those
changes uh it will require this big
marginalization of the farming system
and it does create some interesting
opportunities for investors so one
example is is meat production now you
want to get The Greener engine meat you
know places where the methane and other
sort of risks are manageable but uh
really uh the affluence in Asia is going
to meet much more meat production much
more diets that are similar to Western
diets and a whole range of opportunities
in these sectors that's actually much
more resilient we feel as an investment
Trend than plant-based meats and others
which are languishing at 0.2 percent of
meat consumption yeah but you're also
quite skeptical about the the prospects
of the cultivated meat sector
cultivated meats you know you can get
chicken nuggets now in Singapore Israel
is doing some work but it's pretty
limited uh essentially they're about
hundreds of firms all small very and
clear as an investor which one will
succeed which one won't I think it's
much more place where government comes
in and does primary research and we're
still 10 years away when investors find
a clear winner where they should go
after that and in particular it's going
to be easier and I think for much
simpler proteins you know we are not
going to have sort of prime rib sticks
out of cultivated Meats over the next 10
years but you might get egg whites that
go into cakes and so on that will be
created through these means that's
probably where investors should go but
more in VC and I think still where
government rather than private investors
will find Opportunities over the next
five years all right Tommy there's so
much more I wanted to ask you but I'm a
favor out of time but it's a fascinating
paper thanks for talking it through with
us thank you
a bit more breaking news to bring you
now uh the Duke of Sussex has lost a bid
to bring a second High Court challenge
against the home office over his
security Arrangements when visiting the
UK or Royal correspondent Laura bundock
has the details Laura
well security has always been a hugely
contentious issue for Prince Harry ever
since he left his role as a senior
working role he's not entitled to
security or automatic police protection
when he or his family are in the UK he
was challenging that decision and this
case was in particular about the
decision not to let him pay for his own
protection now Harry's lawyers had
argued that this question about whether
or not he could pay for it had not been
taken correctly he said that it had been
taken by ravik which is this executive
committee for the protection of royalty
and VIP so it should have been taken his
lawyers claimed by the home office
instead they'd argued that under the
police Act of 1996 there was provision
for private individuals to be able to
pay for their own policing however when
this preliminary hearing was heard at
the high court the Met Office made it
very clear they thought this would be
unjust that you should have wealthy
individuals able to pay for their own
police saying that it was not a fair
decision not a fair situation and it
wasn't right that the Richer people
richer people should be able to play for
policing this way Harry has lost this
appeal this he was wanting a judicial
review Into the decision he has lost
that bid today this is just one of a
couple of cases he has about this
decision regarding his security he's
also challenging how that original
decision was taken and don't forget
we've also got the phone hacking cases
underway as well at the high quarters
well the most important the most
prominent of those is this full trial at
the moment against mirror group
newspapers but the breaking news today
is that Harry has lost one of his bids
about the security situations he will
not be able to challenge this decision
taken that he cannot pay for his own
policing
okay thanks Laura
our recent updates from the commercial
property sector have pointed to the
Damage Done to the sector over the last
17 months by Rising interest rates
they've impacted some property
valuations as well as hitting
development activity will today ashurer
the leading Primary Care property
investor and developer reported a
pre-tax loss of 119.2 million pounds for
the air to the end of March that
compared with a profit of 155.8 million
pounds in the same period a year ago and
reflected a write down in the value of
the company's property portfolio will
joining me now for more on this is the
chief executive of Ashura Jonathan
Murphy Jonathan good to see you again
this morning I mean the key Point here
is this is a non-cash write down and
your rental income was actually up 9.1
percent
yeah absolutely I mean you said at the
start that all all commercial property
companies have been impacted and I'm
afraid we're no different so yeah but
overall we had a six percent write down
in the in the property value that's a
lot less than most other companies have
seen and that reflects the fact that you
know all our buildings are occupied by
government-backed tenants who've got
very long-term secure
um uh tenancies in place and and the
cash flows are rock solid as you say so
you know nine percent growth in our net
rental income which is giving us the
confidence to announce a you know
another increase in the dividend so uh
yes we we feel of course we're affected
but we feel we're in a very strong
position good to hear now the sale end
of last year you said that you were
going to be slightly more cautious about
developments in in the near term has
anything changed since then to alter
your thinking
yeah no we remain remain active so we
have going on site with 10 schemes at
the moment and we we've got plans to
start five schemes you know but if you
ask me that question six months ago we
probably were looking to start in double
digits so yes we are reducing the number
of new projects and those are you know
essential Healthcare facilities that we
were looking to deliver but the problem
we've faced is rising construction costs
yeah I'm sure you've you've you've read
about that for the house building sector
as well so you know with those Rising
costs it takes uh we then need to pass
that on unfortunately that extra cost to
the NHS in terms of higher rents and
that always gonna that's gonna take a
long time in terms of those negotiations
so we're just moving a little bit more
cautiously on some of those developments
but all those projects are still
required we're still very confident we
will deliver them but just probably
going to take a little longer than we
would have liked what would you need to
see Jonathan to make you start deploying
capital a little more aggressively
I would be very straight I mean if we
were able to achieve you know the
increased rent levels that we that the
costs are requiring um if the NHS was
able to meet those additional costs then
we would be willing to start the
projects tomorrow yeah those are
conversations that we've got going uh
right across the country we've got you
know got projects right across the UK
that we're looking to to roll out
um and in some in some places we are
seeing agreements on those on those
increased costs and and we'll press on
with those so yeah an increase in the
overall rent position would enable us to
move much faster on these new projects
you mentioned you were seeing higher
development costs give me give me an
idea of the sort of scale of the
increases that you've been experiencing
uh well over the last two or three years
it's you know it's in excess of 50 so I
mean very significant increases I mean
currently what we're asking the NHS to
fund to reflect that you know is is
probably a minimum of 30 increase in the
rent level which is very challenging of
course you know for uh for the NHS at a
time when the when the when the budgets
are under pressure but the lack of
facilities also causes costs in the
system in other ways so you know if if
you can't be treated in in a community
facility in your GP surgery and you have
to go to hospital that's much more
expensive for the system so it's a
little bit of false economy
unfortunately we you know if we could
invest in in modern out of Hospital
facilities then then overall for the NHS
that would see cost four but you know in
the short term it's it's an increase in
that rent level now we've talked about
this before Jonathan but for the benefit
of uh new viewers so give me an idea of
how often rents are reviewed in in the
portfolio yeah so um so so that we have
a standard um agreement with the NHS so
we typically have a 21-year lease and we
look at the rent every three years and
every three years it's assessed in light
of the other the rent levels for other
medical centers in that location so it's
a three yearly uh rent review pattern
now we have other tenants like
um Pharmacy tenants where it's it's just
based on indexation so it looks at CPI
but for the NHS it's effectively an open
market review every three years now
you've also got a growing Irish business
what do you seeing in Ireland
yeah no island is it's got very similar
drivers to the UK so um you know they
have a need for investment in out of out
of hostile capacity we've got uh two
projects that we've completed we're on
site with another two and we've got
three starting shortly so it's it's a
very similar Market to the UK in terms
of that need for investment
um and we see significant scope for us
to expand over there as well so small
scale at the moment
um but clearly plenty of potential for
further growth over over the RSC as well
yes now in the recent past you've not
been afraid of disposing of property
assets where you've you've seen the need
to what are you doing on that front
right now
yeah so I mean clearly the markets are
more challenging so you've got to you've
you've got to look to self-help in terms
of uh looking to fund the growth in the
business so you'll be disposed of um you
know 65 Assets in the first half of last
year and we were able to sell those at
above Book value that's that's a
fantastic outcome in this market and I
think that reflects the fact that you
know there is still real interest in the
market in healthcare assets such as ours
um you know people recognize the
long-term Trend you know the need for
increased capacity in the space and so
so they're still very attractive so yeah
we'll we will continue to look at
further disposals as we move forward
because because we want to provide that
flexibility to enable us to move on
those new projects for the NHS as soon
as we can get those rents agreed all
right Jonathan we've got to leave it
there it's good to see you again this
morning thank you brilliant thank you
very much
foreign
have a lookout this morning's business
pages and the financial times splashes
its print edition with a story we
brought you this time yesterday the
record 1.2 billion Euro fine meted out
to meta platforms by the EU the ft is
currently leading its Digital Editions
meanwhile with an interview with Rachel
Reeves in which the shadow Chancellor
tells the paper that a labor government
would be prepared to force Pension funds
to invest in a proposed 50 billion pound
future growth fund it would have five
percent of every defined contribution
schemes assets invested in it Daily
Telegraph splashes its print edition
with an interview with sir Nigel Wilson
the outgoing chief executive of legal
and General in which he tells the paper
London is falling behind rival Financial
Centers as a result of over-regulation
and misguided political interventions
dating back to Gordon Brown's tax rate
on pensions since 1997. remember it like
it was yesterday it leaves its business
Pages meanwhile with news that the
entrepreneur Mike Ashley is mounting an
incursion onto the board of the luxury
hambam maker Mulberry in which is
Fraser's group owns a 37 stake the times
meanwhile it leads its business pages
with the meta find but it also reports
on a court case yesterday in which the
businessman Anthony constantano has been
found guilty in his absence of a 70
million pound fraud that promised
investors a 60 percent annual return
well with me today is Jurgen Meyer the
UK industrialist and former Chief
Executive at Siemens UK Jurgen good to
see you this morning let's start with uh
these comments from Rachel Reeves
because I mean goes on to say this was
actually the brainchild of Nicholas
lines the Lord mayor of the city of
London and she and labor are embracing
it
indeed yeah well look as you know Ian
I'm a massive fan of the startup
especially startup technology companies
and uh and they do need more investment
especially early stage Capital
um so uh on the one hand I think this is
this is fantastic news
um what is really interesting is you say
is that this is a labor party Rachel
Reeves uh proposing this
um you would normally see it as more of
a conservative policy but look let's
take that as positive news that uh
politics is agreed on this I guess what
will raise some eyebrows however is the
use of the word Force so this is
implying that it will be legislated that
pension schemes yours mine every one of
your listeners today and that five
percent of their private pension can be
invested in these startup companies and
of course that goes with some risk and I
suspect there will be required some
discussion about who really has the
responsibility for that risk can the
regulator do that or should the trustees
of the pension scheme be able to
ultimately decide so look it's a good
discussion a good debate and uh and uh
but I think there's some discussion to
go yeah completely we actually had Nick
line on the program when he first uh
proposed this and I sort of put it to
him this smacks a bit of North Korea
telling Pension funds what to invest in
he pushed back at that
did he yeah well uh look
um I can say the the intent is right and
we probably have become too risk-averse
in our pension schemes but I personally
would fall short of forcing trustees to
have to do this I think it has to be an
encouragement and an incentivization
mechanism rather than legislation yeah
it's all about incentives isn't it now
you're delighted on another story in the
uh ft here post brexit UK Investments
Drive FDI in Germany to record levels
yeah so this is fascinating especially
for somebody who uh spends a lot of time
in Germany and the UK
um now it's been widely reported that
the UK has sort of lost its shine on
foreign direct investment
um and that indeed the pole position
within Europe is now held by France not
the UK
um but what I hadn't appreciated and
probably many of your listeners is that
our outflow of investment so British
companies investing in Europe that that
has gone up and it's particularly gone
up uh into Germany indeed
um the article here saying that it's
risen by 21
um over uh the previous year and what
this is showing is that it is British
companies looking to invest in Europe
using Germany as a key location because
those companies want better access
to the single Market which is of course
restricted uh to us otherwise outside of
brexit so look the summary is is the UK
remains a strong place for foreign
direct investment also as an outward
investment but brexit has clearly taken
the Shine off it and is meaning that
we're actually exporting more of our
investing than importing yeah it's an
interesting piece Jurgen we have to
leave it there I'm afraid good to see
you this morning thank you
thank you bye-bye
more breaking news to bring you the
international monetary fund has said it
is not now expecting the UK to enter a
recession this year will join me now as
our economics editor Ed Conway I mean
there are quite a few other forecasters
have said this year IMF playing a bit of
catch up here is it
um yeah I mean it's it's a big change
from their previous forecast but to be
honest with you and you know you I
remember we had exactly this
conversation about the reliability of of
any forecast right now to be honest with
you but in particular IMF forecasts the
last time they made a forecast about the
UK which was to say that Britain was
going to face the weakest economic
growth in the G7 this year that was
widely reported uh at the time it was
what the IMF was saying and it was quite
a big four you know it was a big call to
say the UK was going to have a recession
and then most other countries around the
Europe and indeed the rest of the
industrialized World we're going to do a
lot better but now it's pretty much a
reversal of that they are saying that
the UK is not going to face a recession
this year it's going to be 0.4 growth
not very strong growth but nonetheless a
lot better than the minus 0.3 I think it
was minus 0.5 previously they upgraded a
little bit and now they've upgraded
created it even more and also there will
be other potentially economies within
the G7 which will do worse than the UK
there's this year you were just talking
about Germany it looks like German
growth is forecast by the IMF to be kind
of close to zero so the UK at 0.4 as I
say not nothing to write home about but
nonetheless a lot better than we
previously saw it's actually no longer
the worst performance in the G7 in 2023
so that will be seen as a big victory
for Jeremy Hunt or well I mean a minor
Victory but nonetheless a victory
compared with where they uh were before
the big picture though the UK pretty
much kind of if not flatlining them very
weak growth for the next few years still
very high inflation in fact they've
pushed up their forecast for inflation
they say the bank of England may have to
do or they're recommended the bank of
England should do more interest rate
hikes you can see Andrew Bailey they're
just there is being quizzed by the
treasury select committee right now and
inflation's still a big pressure in the
UK but really it's that big headline
number that I imagine most Focus will be
on so much noise uh I think it was
towards the start of this year when the
IMF said the UK was going to fare the
worst in the G7 well that is no longer
the case they say the UK it's not
necessarily going to go be going
gangbusters this year but at 0.4 growth
no recession and no longer the weakest
growth in uh all of the G7
all right Ed thanks for that
our report published last week by The
Business Services Group PWC in
conjunction with the UK space agency
revealed that after the United States
the UK has become the most attractive
investment market for private investment
in space well since 2015 the UK has
received 17 of global investment in the
space sector with UK space organizations
receiving investments from at least
seven of the most active Global
Investors one of the leading investors
in space Tech is seraphim space
Investment Trust which today reported a
half a million pound drop in the value
of its portfolio to 180.5 million pounds
for the three months to the end of March
joining me now is the chief executive of
seraphim space Mark boggett Mark welcome
to you I mean your share price is
trading at a 59 discount to net asset
value what is the market not getting
right about your portfolio yeah well the
the the the the good news is from our
perspective is that um our peers who
also are public companies investing into
private uh companies are also sitting on
um similar discounts so it isn't
necessarily focused on space or on
seraphim it's really on the on the asset
class that we invest into but the the
valuation is uh is significant our
market capitalization 90 million pounds
today versus now assets of 222 million
so taking into account our 40 million of
cash that means that our portfolio is
valued at just 50 million now our
largest portfolio company isi is valued
at 43 million and that company's just
completed its best ever quarter record
levels of of revenues record levels of
bookings they've just announced a major
Milestone deal with the UAE government
so our biggest company is absolutely
thriving as are many of our or uh at
many of our companies in our top 10 and
Beyond you know the PWC um report that
you referenced there really does
demonstrate real growth um in the market
there's another huge driver that's been
going on during the course of the last
quarter that's impacted our portfolio
and that's around change in regulation
so you'll be aware of debris in space
and the increasing number of satellites
that are being launched have the
potential to increase this debris and
and The Regulators have now focused on
that and the FCC has now changed the
rules so that um you have to remove a
satellite end of life after only five
years previously that used to be 25
years so that is really impacting three
of our portfolio companies the orbit has
had their best ever quarter they've had
multiple successful launches they've won
a handful of uh of contracts that are
worth tens of millions of dollars or uh
our Japanese company Astro scale has
just closed a massive funding around 75
million dollars at the price of last
year's funding round and our other
portfolio company in the top 10 that's
focused on debris in space Leo Labs is
having a really strong period as well so
our pedestrian numbers are really not
sort of reflecting what's going on in
the actual underlying portfolio yeah
good to have that detailed breakdown
Mark I mean the the broader picture here
as well is that uh the cost of accessing
space is coming down quite sharply I
mean presumably that is driving
investment as well
yeah absolutely that is what's been
driving investment into the space market
during the course of the last four or
five years they're led by SpaceX but
there's 150 other rocket launch
companies behind them using reusability
3D printed components and then we
recently saw SpaceX launching the
world's largest
um rocket um their starship and that is
really single-handedly going to reduce
the the cost of sending a kilo into
space some Believe by at least a further
50 so the direction of travel is also
positive for the types of companies that
we invest into and it opens up the
market to a much much broader range of
commercial activity what's driving
Demand right now I would assume that
defenses are higher priority than once
was the case yeah absolutely well
because of the geopolitical situation
Ukraine we're now in a period where
defense budgets around the world are at
record highs and Space is really at the
top of their priority for new capability
is that they're looking to invest these
budgets into the number of portfolio
companies through seraphim that are
operating and supporting activities in
Ukraine has really shot a light on the
capabilities of these companies that are
providing data and Communications from
this new digital infrastructure
um in the sky the the other driver is
climate and sustainability the vast
majority of our companies are dual use
the the they they support defense but
they also support climate and uh with
with the climate-induced weather events
just increasing um around the world
there is a need to better Monitor and
protect ourselves against those and the
types of companies that we invest into
are very much focused around that and
that's a consequence that their revenues
are are driving positively all right
Mark gotta leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you thank you
now Ryan as results yesterday along with
other recent trading updates from the
likes of EasyJet and Tui have
highlighted the strength with which the
travel and tourism sectors are bouncing
back all of which has benefited SSP
which operates restaurants bars cafes
and other food and drink outlets in
airports and Railway stations around the
world for the company whose Brands
include Upper Crust and retart Sir today
announced an underlying operating profit
of 34.4 million pounds for the six
months to the end of March like compared
to the loss of 36.4 million pounds in
the same period last year SSP also
announced a partnership with brewdog
that will see it operate a number of
Brew dog bars at airport and Railway
stations in the UK to be opened over the
next few years the first of which will
be at Gatwick Airport well joining me
now I'm very pleased to say it's Patrick
coveny the chief executive of SSP
Patrick good to see you this morning I
mean it's fair to say that while there
is a bounce back it's been fairly uneven
hasn't it I mean the US has kind of led
the way
yeah no it it looks that way
um but it's it's actually surprisingly
consistent so what I mean by that Ian is
the
um our business in the air channel uh in
aviation you referenced Ryanair earlier
um you know we're seeing that be strong
everywhere and so you know we're now
back essentially back to where we were
in traveler numbers uh pre-covert
um and our business in America is a
hundred percent here whereas if I
contrasted to our business in the UK
which is about half rail or half air the
mix effect of that means that the the UK
growth doesn't show up as strongly as
the as the us but it's really a function
of rail taking a bit longer to recover
than air it's not because the rail
strikes have hit uh commuter activity
well I think it's it's been um it's been
Amplified by the strikes but I think
even uh separate from that you know you
still have
um flexible working working from home
um a somewhat lower level of commuting
um than you might have seen pre-covered
whereas in the air channel
um people are just taking holidays in a
kind of really really full-on way
um and that strength of leisure travel
um is underpinning the very very rapid
recovery in um in the air business
across the world which you haven't yet
seen to the same extent in real
now you've stepped up per site openings
uh over the last nine months or so the
US particularly but it also markets like
India Malaysia and Thailand what do you
look for when you open a new site
yeah I mean we're looking for three
things really we're looking to put sites
in high growth markets and we're looking
for sites in air for Regions and
business models in which we think we can
make money
um and we need to have um kind of the
trust and confidence of the you know
typically the you know the airport
terminal owner
um and the brands that we bring there so
some combination of our own economics
structural growth uh and a genuine
Spirit of partnership
now uh this is the first answer we've
had to speak to you since you joined SSP
we've spoken to you previously when
you're at Green core of course a major
supplier to SSP what's it been like
moving around to the other side of the
table
I tell you what it's been fun to go to
the other side of the table after um
um 15 years of being in one part of the
food value chain it's just I mean I'm
serious not in it's the change for me
has been really invigorating
um and it's been a lot of fun and you
know I'm not I don't pretend that one
part of the value chain is any easier
than the other but it is a little
different and it's been refreshing for
me to make the change and I'm enjoying
it immensely that's good to hear what
about food and drink inflation right now
what are you seeing coming through the
pipeline
well listen the whole industry has been
smashed by inflation for the last um 15
months or so
um and you know you see that with the
understand understandable now public
policy focus on um on food pricing but
you know it's you know it's really a
function of very very significant
pressures they've been put on Supply
chains which have driven up costs so
my expectation
um which is also our planning assumption
is that the rate of inflation will begin
to ease through the rest of this year
um but we're still we're still a bit of
a distance from
um you know deflation and any meaningful
um reductions in food pricing I think
how difficult has that been for you with
some of your premium offerings I mean up
across the clue is in the name this this
is a a premium offering has has it been
difficult to pass on price increases in
certain segments
well well I think we're I think we're
very fortunate relative to
um you know other retailers other Food
Service operators or other participants
in the food industry in that
um we tend to operate in locations where
consumers choose to be less price
sensitive than they may otherwise be
because you know we're typically
providing food for people and having
some kind of a treats right going on a
holiday going on a weekend away
um and in that environment provided we
get the service right The Culinary
credentials right provided we reduce
stress and don't run the risk of like
being slow and and you know contributing
to customers being stressed out where
they're going to get their flights
um we don't tend to see the same level
of price elasticity that you see in
other channels um and so what that's
meant is we've got to be careful about
this but where we've had to recover
inflation through pricing we haven't
seen the types of elasticity effects
that you might see in other channels
um now we keep you know we keep
monitoring that and we want to make sure
that we do have
propositions that cater for very price
conscious customers but in general what
we find is that consumers are willing to
pay a bit more when they're going on
their holiday
um and when they have it when they're
getting a very very good experience in
an airport or rail station yeah that
figures now tell me about the uh the
type with Brew dog was it was this uh
their instigation or yours
I think it's both actually I mean we're
um we're constantly on the lookout for
Brands and Concepts that we think will
work in a travel environment and that we
can somewhat travelize to use that
expression in other words figure out a
supply chain and a staffing model
um and a you know kind of capital build
and a business design that works in a in
a travel environment
um we think the world of blue dog is a
brand and as a proposition
um and it's part of a kind of
revitalization and excitement that we're
putting into
um into our UK business and so it's not
the only one
um I mean we're we're we're psyched to
be announcing this today and you're
going to see it in Gatwick later this
summer and you'll see it in a rail
um a number of Rail stations by the end
of the year as well
um and you know it's a privilege for us
to be able to bring a iconic brand like
that to a travel environment so we're um
we're delighted to be doing this and um
and we'll have to do it well we also
have other brands though that we're
bringing this year you know we're doing
we're bringing The Breakfast Club to
Gatwick
um we've actually you know we've we've
launched um and travelized three
um uh Greg's Outlets two and rail one in
air uh this year as well and so we're
constantly looking to try to find the
right
um High Street brands that we can bring
and make relevant to people when they're
traveling very good Patrick it's great
to see you again thanks very much for
joining me today yeah thanks Ian stay
well bye-bye
that's it from me just a reminder you
can carry on watching the treasury
select committee by following the code
on our screen I'm back tomorrow on
location meanwhile we got the podco show
hope to see you then cheerio
[Music]